das war laut was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich habe
ein super interessantes thema hier
zugeschickt bekommen also das haben wir
viele bei instagram höhe alex ross sagst
du dazu und ein kollege den ich privat
hat mir sogar post abgeschickt habe ich
mir die ersten drei minuten vom video
angeschaut und dachte mir eigentlich
kann man darauf meine reaction drehen
weil ich finds selber sehr sehr
interessant was sie sagen werden weil
ich super informiert was das thema
angeht muss ich sagen also es geht um
saturn mystery boxen
ich habe von anfang an auch immer welche
bestellt hier liegt auch noch ein oder
zumindest ist der karton noch da es geht
nämlich um dieses video christoph
verarscht die wahrheit über seine 600
euro mystery box und warum saturn sich
darüber freut genau also viele von euch
haben ja auch meine videos geschaut zu
den mystery boxen drop hat auch videos
dazu gemacht zusammen mit diemer die
waren auch die ersten die es gemacht
haben ich habe das so zu sagen bei denen
gesehen habe selber geschaut und bin
dann über ebay auf die ebay seite von
saturn dortmund gestoßen und die haben
halt diese boxen verkauf und roboter
auch eine box für 2000 euro mit 6000
euro warenwert und anscheinend soll das
laut denen jetzt hier wohl fake gewesen
sein
wir schauen einfach mal rein ich bin
sehr gespannt letzte überraschung
darüber haben zusätzlich ein buchstabe
könnte man auf den wortwitz kommen aber
das ist nur meine meinung jeder dafür
seine eigene man also vielleicht ganz
kurz noch der kanal offen und ehrlich
gehört funk an also wird gesponsert von
den öffentlich-rechtlichen also von uns
allen eigentlich deswegen haben die echt
immer viel cash für die videos und ich
muss sagen die videos sind an sich auch
immer sehr nice und lustig also ich
schaue mir die gerne mal an das
vielleicht vorweg
normale menschen was solche ski war die
heftigste missouri box die geöffnete
male menschen das sind also ich habe mir
schon gedacht dass ich bestimmt auch da
drin bin aber das wird er jetzt direkt
schon mal krass hier wird schon mal
direkt krass eingestiegen sag ich mal so
haben du café ihrer box und überhaupt
gleich eine ganze kaffeemaschine okay
dann muss ich mal ganz kurz ein haken
also ich bin mir absolut auf keine seite
stellen erstmalig muss aber auch sagen
dass sich rob und die man sehr sehr
sympathisch finde und ich bin eigentlich
nicht vorstellen kann dass die extra
irgendwie da was faken dass er halt vor
die krasse sachen drin sind und halt so
aufbringt bronze niveau die zuschauer so
ein bisschen hinter das licht für
möchten das glaube ich nicht die haben
das jetzt gerade so mit diesen zwischen
schnitten so dargestellt als wäre bei
mir immer nur scheiß drin gewesen und
bei robotern der playstation
kaffeemaschine und so da muss ich sagen
ich hatte auch ein iphone 3 von 8 was
wirklich ganz nice war und es war viel
schrott drin bei boppard im großen und
ganzen schon deutlich geile sachen drin
aber ich hatte nicht nur schlechtes sag
ich mal so also die haben im prinzip
alles aus ihrer ramp kiste einfach nur
in solche boxen getan
kaffee kommt überhaupt den ersten seiten
dort auch nur müll und vieler lampen
aber plötzlich nur noch krassen scheiß
in einer box für 2000 euro hatte er in
sachen im wert von 6000 euro
da muss ich mal kurz ein grätschen das
war auch der sinn also die haben auch
damit geworben
es gab 200 euro boxen aktuell gibt es
sie gar nicht mehr es gibt noch welche
von saturn mönchengladbach oder so die
bei dem aus gladbach kosten zum beispiel
200 euro du hast auch nur ein warenwert
von 320 euro da drin aber die saturn
dortmund boxen hatten immer den
dreifachen warenwert also wenn du für
200 euro bestellt hast hattest du 600
euro ich habe für 500 euro bestellt
hatte 1500 euro wenn du für 2000 euro
bestellt was hattest du 6000 euro
deswegen an sich erstmal von real
wie kann man auf diesen dazu vielleicht
ganz kurz noch also es ist ja nicht
direkter verlustes sind sachen die über
einen langen zeitraum nicht verkauft
wurden habe ich mir auch gedacht bei dem
iphone 8 hatten anscheinend noch sehr
viele davon sind die nicht los geworden
und haben es dann in die box getan auch
der gaming laptop ihr gerade den die
gezogen haben wollte vielleicht keine
haben auch wenn er 3500 euro kostet ich
weiß nicht ich bin gespannt was noch
kommt
kat hannaford hartung
und auch wir wurden stutzig denn wir
haben eine verdächtige ebay-auktion band
sind in dieser ersten box nur scheiß
sachen drin ansonsten nichts zu erzählen
ist ein tag später zwölfter oktober bei
ebay-auktionen gerade 40 euro boxen von
saturn chris rock schlägt zu diesmal
wenn ich online auf die suche gegangen
und hab gesehen hat dann muss ich auch
ganz kurz was zu sagen die erste box
weswegen ich erhofft die ganze sache
aufmerksam geworden bin oder die ersten
boxen die die geöffnet haben waren nicht
vom saturn dortmund soweit ich weiß sie
hat er aus irgendeinem saturn abgeholt
und die saturn dortmund boxen habe ich
dann irgendwann entdeckt habe die
bestell und danach kam dann auch bei
denen das video ich weiß nicht ob sich
selber schon vorher gesehen haben oder
dann bei mir gesehen haben auf jeden
fall kam dann bei denen auch ein video
mit den saturn dortmund mystery boxen ja
also das zweite wo dann plötzlich
bessere sachen drin waren also das war
nicht der gleiche anbieter schon
merkwürdig oder das einen tag nach der
ersten box von krispy robin der nur
scheiße war und landen kommt dann
plötzlich eine ebay-auktion wenn wir
haben es hier sogar stehen kommentiert
hatte christoph etwa heimlich was mit
saturn gedealt erwarten jetzt wirklich
dicke 3
man muss mal davon ausgerechnet dann
jemand nichts tun um nur den kunden zu
beglücken sondern dass vor allem das
unternehmensinteresse dahinter steht
die 300 euro gezahlt konnte diese auch
ziehen und wirklich serie steigt
die videos sind auch immer so in die
fresse aktie in diesem video gibt's
antworten und jetzt kannst du dich noch
mal vor dass unsere beste und einzige
reportern ich meine technik also
verstehe ich die technik nicht ganz so
mitarbeiterin des monats gewählt worden
liebe kinder in schwetzingen gewünscht
danke
diese zwei youtuber die haben angebissen
bei den konnten wir unseren ganzen
ramsch ich meine unsere mystery boxen
loswerden das ding ist ja in der
allerersten box hatten diese zwei
unschuldigen youtuber ja ziemlich viel
scheiß drin also ich weiss mal zusammen
lampen lampen und noch mehr noch mal
weil das waren auch das sieht man auch
ganz klar im design von diesen kartons
die war nichts vom saturn dortmund
dieser nämlich anders aus dass die aso
restposten unseren kamen gut verpacken
können und auch die glücksspielsucht der
menschen vertrauen und somit hat die
dinger raus was heißt schlecht
zum beispiel das war nicht so eine geile
werbeblocks ehrlich gesagt ja die erste
aber lasst uns doch lieber über die
zweite sprechen
ich war schon mal gern durchgehend war
es da wirklich drin war in dieser box
kommt hierbei der kaffeemühle
da sieht man ja ganz eindeutig dass dir
schon mal auf waren oder erst ein
festnetztelefon rein gemacht das war ja
schon mal reduziert ne gegen wieder im
kopf die haben ja auch schon heute fest
das telefon scheint ja ich glaub ich
hatte auch ein festnetztelefon geil
alter festnetztelefone sein dass er hier
euren alten stand da in diesen kisten
entleert kommen gerade vielleicht auch
die festnetz geräte jetzt gar nicht mehr
so aktuell gefragt sind und man die dann
eben an den mann bringt dann natürlich
mag das sein dass man die eine oder
andere gute sache drin so ist arbeitet
ist natürlich eher ein spiel es ist eine
wette es ist ein glücksspiel
letztendlich also halten wir mal
festival christina was auch immer diese
diese frau die expertin das sind mir
immer die besten sind so in so gerade
auch in so fernsehinterviews dann immer
irgendwelche experten die promi expertin
alter da krieg ich echt zu viel wenn ich
solche leute sehen die sind
hauptberuflich promi experte damit halt
möglichst seriös rüberkommen was auch
immer diese frau beruflich macht
der ersten box nur schrott und dann hat
sich das plötzlich verändert dann ist
was passiert dann haben sie ja noch zwei
boxen gekauft und plötzlich war noch
krasse sachen drin zum beispiel rolle
denn das ist ja schon ein bisschen
verdächtigten erster ganze schaut in der
kiste und plötzlich die teuren sachen
die er noch viel mehr wert sind als der
kaufpreis der box also ich frage mich ja
zum beispiel rollen hätten im laden
jedoch noch verkaufen könnt oder einen
gaming laptop der preis wurde im laptop
dies allein 100.000 aber hatte halt
keiner gekauft das ist das ding der
youtuber dave hat auch so eine box
bestellt und der hatte so ein huawei p20
made glaube ich heißt dass so ein klapp
handy für 1700 euro und dazu war meine
erklärung auch dass es halt vermutlich
nicht verkauft wurde oder nicht viel
verkauft wurde und die hatten noch genug
von den dingern über das packst du doch
nicht ohne not in seine box rein also
viele fans vermuten ja vielleicht auch
so recht dass das eine geheime
werbeaktion war vor sator und wert
natürlich nicht
außerdem will das auch gar nicht zugeben
das war jetzt nicht werbung im
eigentlichen sinne sagen immer so gern
einfach ein bisschen glücksfee gespielt
am christi rob zu diesem paket die hat
er bei ebay gekauft
diesmal wenn ich online auf die suche
gegangen und hab gesehen dass saturn
einen eigenen ebay account verstehe ich
das richtig ein saturn mystery box gab
es plötzlich bei e mail
die habe da selbst höher eingestellt ist
schon richtig aber alles der reihe nach
nach so ganzer mann am 11.10
veröffentlichtes video das mit den
ganzen lampen und dem ganzen schrott
das war furchtbar schlechte werbung für
uns und einen tag später am 12 10 haben
wir dann diese idee aktion gestartet mit
liebe aktion ja andere boni aktion sagen
die aktion sagt ja war ja keine auktion
kommt man einfach kaufen muss niemand
auf die eier dann natürlich aktion ja
richtig ja also es gibt ganz viele
saturn-märkte die haben einfach ein
eigenes e mail konto und da gibt es dann
die gleichen boxen zu klären im laden
natürlich nicht gewährt da gab es dann
natürlich die boxen mit den geilen
scheiß hallo
bis zum 19 10 wurden da mehrere 350 euro
boxen verkauft er heute kostet jeder
dieser boxen 350 euro und der wagen wer
heute bei knapp über 2.000 euro und am
20 10 sogar eine für 2000 euro und der
kauften aber die gab es auch länger weil
ich war kurz davor die selber zu kaufen
und dann war sie weg die box für 2000
euro
das hier ist eine 2000 euro mystery box
mit einem gewicht von 162 kilogramm also
wir halten mal ganz kurz fest rob hat
ein video gemacht indem er saturn
mystery boxen ausgepackt hat da war nur
scheiße drin und dann hat sich laut
offen und ehrlich der großkonzern saturn
gedacht wir müssen dagegen was machen
wir stellen jetzt weitere boxen bei ebay
ein und tun hat wirklich nur geile
scheiße rein
ich weiß nicht ob die jetzt wirklich
genau deswegen diesen großen aufwand
betreiben um halt das image sozusagen
dadurch wieder aufzupolieren weil nur
weil bei denen jetzt nur lampen drin
waren hat saturn ja jetzt kein mega
schaden bei media markt zum beispiel
habe ich auch box bestellt da ist noch
mehr drin
6000 cook du kannst deren begeisterung
messen mit den geräuschen die wieder zu
machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wer also wie dir das zusammengeschnitten
haben finde ich echt lustig
und wie klingt das kind nur nicht
richtig frei ist dass ich von saturn
warum machen die das mit diesen boxen
also was hat saturn davon ja seit wann
hat einmal einmal natürlich die
gelegenheit dass die boxen packen können
da können sie noch unbeliebter
einziger haken die sich gut verkaufen
lassen spielmaschine einiger man kann
auch aufmerksam machen in der
werbeaktion super hier box billig und
darf ihn erwarten aber so besonders
seriös wirkt eure auktion oder eure
aktion ja nicht nur wir müssen uns aber
mit ihm geschrieben einmal mit
ja das habe ich mir auch aufgefallen da
war vielleicht der praktikant am berg
das wirkt so ein bisschen als hätte man
die auktion zur reaktion ganz schnell
online stellen wollte vielleicht
innerhalb von 24 stunden nachdem das
lappen geht die online kam damit man
ganz schnell von diesem werbe disaster
ablenken kann wäre gut aber wie
wahrscheinlich war es denn bitte dass er
die aktion mitkriegt bayer hätte sie mir
bescheid sagen ja aber dafür hätte er
seine telefonnummer gebraucht moment bei
einer saturn filiale und einmal genommen
da lassen und dieser hat dann gestern
abend angerufen und ich bin heute schon
mit vollgas gefahren hat uns übrigens
auf rückfrage bestätigt das ist die
ebay-auktion wirklich gab das aber nur
lokale option gewesen ist die
mittlerweile beendet gewesen sei ich
habe hier schon wieder neues angebot in
der pubertät kann
das ist halt jetzt von saturn
schließlich tot also nicht mehr dortmund
ach so das kann ich natürlich muss das
video zu ende schon erstmal bevor ich
noch was zusammen
ich muss jetzt mal kurz das packen wir
nächsten box hier so ein bisschen
koordinieren leute das paar passe ja
ganz ganz ganz ganz oben drauf genau
über den lamborghini duo 6490 euro gibt
demnächst raus was war es genau was ein
paar welches ich weiß nicht warum das zu
teuer ist aber es ist ein sehr teures 1
ohne scheiß unter allen teuren dingen
die wir so einfallen fällt ihr als
erstes fabergé ei was sagt das über dich
aus was mir aber übrigens noch aus
gefunden haben online machen diese
müssten die boxen eigentlich gar keinen
sinn denn wenn er den 14 tägiges
rückgaberecht das heißt wenn wir in der
box nicht gefällt kann ich sie einfach
zurückgeben und jetzt wurde mir das geld
zurückerstattet bekämen was sagst du
dazu
dazu sage ich leute wusstet ihr dass er
uns das alles zurück lebt pharma die
lamborghini wieder auf ein paket aus dem
laden gekauft habe ich hab ich kein
rückgaberecht also da wird das wenn ich
vom umtausch ausgeschlossen sind ist das
eben so muss ich akzeptieren habe ich im
internet gekauft habe ich natürlich das
widerrufsrecht
moment mal kurz dann kann ich ja die
mediamarkt boxen in den absoluten was
drin war wieder zurück vielleicht mache
ich das einfach nur um den einen rein zu
drücken damit irgend wer den aufwand
machen muss und dass wieder in die
buchhaltung abführen muss der prosieben-
taktik dass ich sagt ich behalte das
iphone und der rest kommt zurück sondern
dann natürlich die ganze box zusammen
zurück nachdem ich würd mal sagen du
dich wir werden heute hier keine kunden
und verkäuferin beziehungen eingehen
denn ich kauf mir heute keine mystery
box aber ich gehe mal dass so ein paar
will ich habe noch gar kein
weihnachtsgeschenk für dich aber
möglicherweise springt das mein
taschengeld budget auch ein bisschen
möglicherweise ja das war es jetzt
tatsächlich dann auch schon mit dem
video also ich habe eigentlich gedacht
da kommt jetzt noch was krasses am ende
weil im titel steht ja christoph
verarscht gut mit dem fragezeichen aber
dann hier die wahrheit über seine 6000
euro mystery box und warum saturn sich
darüber freut also die haben ja jetzt
einfach mal in den raum geworfen dass
rob ein anruf bekommt von saturn
wir haben extra wegen der neue boxen
reingestellt saturn dortmund hier die
sind volk raster ist nur geil es zeugt
und bestellbar bitte eine & drop hat
dann gesagt klar mach ich aber das ist
ja überhaupt nicht belegt und drückt den
christbaum ob dann schon in den etwas
schlechtes licht würde ich mal sagen
weswegen ich das ein bisschen sehr
schwammig findet weil ich in meinem fall
auch sagen muss ich wusste absolut
nichts von dem ganzen ich habe einfach
auf gut glück bei google saturn misery
box eingeben und dann kam direkt ohne
von ebay saturn dortmund diese ganzen
verschiedenen boxen mit verschiedenen
preisen und ich habe halt einfach eine
bestellt und da waren eigentlich immer
ganz gute sachen drin und meine meinung
ist halt nach wie vor dass es auch bei
diesen ganzen sachen die rock bekommen
hat sei es jetzt dieser e scooter seine
playstation 4
alles sachen sind die jetzt nicht mehr
so krass verkauft werden und von denen
halt einfach noch viel zu viele da sind
ich meine die ps 5 kam raus
elektro scooter haben sich jetzt auch
nicht so mega durchgesetzt zumindest
diese fetten dinge halt wer kauft da
noch ein iphone 8 für 600 euro bei
saturn wenn man auch gebrauchte kaufen
kann und es ist schon ein iphone 12 wer
kauft sich dieses huawei dingen für 1700
euro wer gibt 1000 euro für ein klapp
handy aus das hat sich auch noch nicht
durchgesetzt und deswegen würde ich halt
einfach mal sagen dass niemand etwas
davon wusste und sich natürlich unterm
strich das dingen für saturn sehr
gelohnt hat gute werbung aber hier wird
halt drop bisher ein bisschen verarscht
sage ich mal und ich weiß nicht wir
können super gern mal eure meinung dazu
in die kommentare schreiben
ich lade das video glaube ich sogar auf
meinem hauptkanal hoch und ja danke fürs
zuschauen und das was von mir wir sehen
uns über wochen wieder ich wünsche euch
allen frohe weihnachten verbringt schöne
zeit mit ihrer familie und bleibt gesund
das war's haut rein